if you recall we have been looking at
this idea of integration and
integrations that solving a particular
kind of problem do you remember that
what kind of problem we're trying to
solve area very good the area under a
curve you thing right like we know the
areas of like polygons and we can this
circle is a very specific example but
all those kinds of things we're living
to like the measurement formulas right
so integrals were the idea of what if
trying to divide up this curved area
into and if you remember an infinite
series of infinitesimally thin
rectangles and then you get to make them
you combine them into a hole in it tada
there's your area okay now you might
recall that we said something like this
right this is the way you would find
such an area right if you've got some
function f it traces out curve and the
particular area that you're interested
in the interval over which you will
integrate from A to B that'll give you
the area and I gave this a special name
we called it a definite integral right
so just pop this down just to remind you
and so that by way of contrast you'll
see what I'm talking there today okay
now I said it's called a definite
integral I made no explanation good
morning no explanation as to why was
called back but it does kind of beg the
question what kind of other integrals
are there and the answer is a definite
intervals okay now a definite integral
and an indefinite integral look very
very similar cuz they're both in two
rows here's the difference
and in definite integral has no
boundaries it doesn't have an upper and
lower bound do you like integrating from
here to here right and finding that
little area you just sort of is he ready
right so this is an indefinite integral
now if you recall go back to a definite
integral in right what you do is it's
connected to the primitive function
right you find the primitive of F then
you evaluate it at be as you take away
from evaluating it at a okay so being a
finding the primitive is kind of what is
like the engine that makes this work
fighting an indefinite integral is still
finding that primitive function but then
you just don't evaluated anything into
that okay now this is kind of strange
this is kind of strange because as we
just remove right integrations that
solve this problem of area this doesn't
tell you an area because it's like well
where's your area the answer is it's
nowhere it's not an area okay definite
integrals are a number this is helping
the error is an indefinite integral is a
function in fact it is the premier
function in fact for all intensive
purposes it's another name for the
primitive functions what we get is that
primitive right capital rare and it will
be i'm off by clustered right now I seem
to quickly pause before you go into like
I could just get you to start computing
somebody's in definite integrals right
and believe me you will okay but we have
to ask the question why on earth would
we do this right why wouldn't we leave
behind the boundaries because we the
boundaries are the thing that makes is
useful right there the things that give
you an area okay and to answer that
question I want to point you to this
number now I hope a lot of you recognize
this number what is this number into the
speedo okay Alex move on now that i'm so
glad some people know the difference
that the traditional name for this in
meter per second right is this is the
speed of one okay now we need to pause
on this for a second right and explain
for those of you like me who did it
now window here the physics dads are
299,792,458 meters per second the name
has gotten is the speed of light okay
however it is quite a bit more than the
speed of light the reason it gets the
name the speed of light is because it
was first encountered when physicists
trying to answer two questions number
one is light does light travel
instantaneously right it certainly feels
like a travel instantaneously right but
things you know our perceptions are
quite slow really so we didn't know we
didn't know does it travel
instantaneously or not that was the
first question they answer that question
no it does it right so then of course
the secondary question that it begs is
well if it doesn't travel
instantaneously how fast is a travel
okay now it's a whole another exciting
story about how they determined that
this is how fast they travel right but
since Y and the speed was the problem
they were trying to solve well that's
the name they got attached to this well
it's the speed of light okay but of
course physicist didn't stop there and
they discovered actually it's more than
just the speed of light for starters
it's the speed of everything that
travels it has no mass okay so that
includes photons which means all
electromagnetic radiation travels at
that speed includes anything which
doesn't have mass like for example the
other being table we know about is blue
ones which are the names are the things
that transmit the force that keeps
atomic nuclei together okay also travel
at this speed because they also do not
have mass but it's even more than that
it's even more than a speed and I'm not
going to dig into this at all but
everyone pretty much in the world like
this might be the most famous equation
in the world what it connect what it
connects is the quantity of energy and
the quantity of mass that corresponds to
that amount of energy okay in other
words a little bit of mass is a lot of
energy right because you're multiplying
by this astronomically literally
astronomically large number okay
now hold on why on earth would the speed
of light have anything to do with
connecting these two quantities together
and the answer is this is something
deeper and more profound than just how
fast light travels right it says
something very very deep and amazing
profound about the connection between
energy and mass of relativity right so
this is more than just the speed of
light in exactly the same way that this
is about so much more than area ok this
is the area is the tractor kinda problem
we were trying to initially solve right
but then integration it just it's
amazing right it does a lot more than
just add up a whole bunch of infinitely
thin rectangles ok here's this all right
if we sort of unshackle it away from
this idea of area now I just I can't
help myself I have two very very quickly
give you a taste of what I mean ok
quickly draw for me underneath you right
what we're talking about is something
like okay here's is a function right
here's evaluate he is a value be ok and
this is what I'm adding up like I said
this infinite infinite series of
infinitesimally thin rectangles that's
what it's all about ok but in fact
integrals can add up an infinite series
of infinite sum infinitely small
anything anything ok let me try to
illustrate this where i'm going to get
my strong examples that are really fun
and we're going to blow open the door as
we move further to this topic ok here's
my first funny game we developed this
idea for the area of a circle i'm very
very early on and we do it in a fairly
intuitive way like we divide this thing
up into an infinitesimally sorry i
didn't fit a number of infinite test
within tribal like this ok and that's
what went into it ok but a lot of you
actually some of you explicitly
mentioned to me hold on we know what the
area of a circle is we also know what
the circumference of a circle is and the
second you third differentiation you
look at that you're like what why why is
that why are these two
seemingly connected by differentiation
and the answer is well good morning
they're not so much connected by
differentiation as they are connected by
integration let me show you